freida Pinto joined the cast of Andy  Serkis  Jungle Book origins the actress revealed  her role to ET at the film Independent  Spirit Awards read the jungle book  growing up and watched the TV series in  India growing up and for me to finally  be part of the film that reminds me so  much of my childhood is just animate  it's one of those films that I feel  generate no matter what age group you  are you're gonna enjoy that film and I  feel like this minute Watson's have done  something like that you know because  most of my films have not been good  enough for children you know go to  intense so I'm very happy to finally be  doing a film that can be yeah when are  you playing it five a Mosley's abducted  mother okay I'm very very excited about  it and live action or is it like mocast  mocap live-action marriage okay the  movie is set to hit theaters October  2017 it also stars Christian Bale Cate  Blanchett  and Benedict Cumberbatch